something else that has been so amazing
this season is the return
of some of our beloved favorite iconic
characters yeah patrick dempsey tr
knight
yeah you is someone who is only one of
three og
characters oh geez oh gee
what has that been like for you
so i look at it as a fan of the show
because i have always been
a fan of grey's anatomy since day one
i'm the person that doesn't watch the
episodes until they air
i'm i'm that you know kind of fan of the
show so
yeah you know so i was thinking of it
from a fan point of view
who may not have expected that at all
that was really
exciting for me i was excited for our
fans
to get that opportunity to have that
moment what was it like
to keep that secret well you know that's
what we do
you guys are very good at it by the way
not difficult at all it's like what
secret what you know
we just know it's going to be so much
more exciting for people to actually
watch it
than to tease it or be like oh this is
what's coming it's like no
just let it be just let it let it show
up and see what happens
you and james were in one of the scenes
with t.r
knight talk about just shooting that and
the emotion that you guys
probably i would imagine felt having him
back
with you in person we were all on like a
watch alert is is that somebody over
there are they is that somebody go go go
over there go over there
they got a phone they've got a phone
it was that crazy it was like i think
the ah
no no the the dude the dude on the
surfboard go get him he's got a camera
it was like protect the baby which we
just really wanted it to be a surprise
so we
you know always keep in touch you know
over the years that that relationship
didn't end because the character ended
so
it was you know having the baby back at
home we do know that there's more
mick dreamy to come what can you reveal
about his final
stance with us this season final see
that would
imply that i know what the story is you
know
why do you keep thinking that i know
things because i feel like
if anyone knows that's you and maybe i'd
go with the ellen part before you come
to me but
that's like honest truth i have no idea
of
you know what our plans are what do you
think the beach scenes
signify then the beach was actually a
really cool idea that that came from
krista vernon
she was like okay to starting season in
the pandemic
and that we need to tell that story but
everybody's in tpe
all the time and you know fully masked
how do you see people what do you do
so meredith's gonna go down let's send
it to the beach where everything is calm
and peaceful and you can run your feet
through the sand
and there's no colvin and you know the
wind is blowing
and people are able to kind of come and
visit that realm
and spend time even though you know
we're really not there o'malley's
character was there
able to talk with meredith but richard
and bailey were not we were speaking to
her
in the hospital but as far as she was
concerned everybody's there with her on
this beach
so it's actually become a really
interesting tool
a really interesting vehicle to say
where do you go
and spend your time while you're waiting
for medicine to catch up
who would you love to see return
i am notorious for saying all of the
babies dead or
alive welcome to come back
and spend time at home so that's what
it's fair for
all of the babies i particularly call
them that because once i started
directing in season six
that's what everybody felt like to me
you know my babies and that i was taking
care of these characters and
you know just really thoughtful about
what kind of experience they were having
so that's how they all feel to me bring
them out of the grave
i just
is there a chance that we will see
lexi and mark that seems to be a big oh
that's the draw
that's everybody wants that i mean
everyone wants everyone but
yeah yeah yeah yuri that i've seen and
and them together
right it's like you have to you have to
know that they had
their happily ever after after the plane
crash
they're together for happy endings
that's very very cute that would be very
very cute
again grip by script that's all this one
right here knows
you james ellen the only three og's
left on the show what does that
feel like for you guys i think as an
actor
you would love to be a starter and a
finisher of a thing
right to have that kind of longevity i
know what that means to me like these
are like my actor dreams come true
but even in a bigger sense than that
grace has meant so much
socially it's meant so much to our
culture
to american culture and then globally
people relate to these characters and
care about these characters so i love
what we've been able to accomplish as
far as television
is concerned and what television looks
like and what images
are are you know are portrayed so i'm
incredibly honored at having been able
to be
a part of this all this time and that
you know our relevance is still
right there we kind of ride the
relevance wave
as it goes along season after season of
the season yeah
do the three of you ever sit around and
talk to each other
say things like wow can you believe it's
still
us three like have those moments
together
we have like you know o.g handoff
you know you got a high five on the way
you know
you got it you got it go ahead i started
it you take us out
you know let's get this day done so yeah
we
certainly that but we are very very
aware of the like the set
appreciation live there for the fact
that that
you know we're still there carrying this
thing and keeping folks employed and
um you know trying to keep people safe
and trying to keep people healthy and
figuring out
how do we do this thing how do we get
people to work
and also you know make sure that they're
not only safe here but then safe when
they go back home like
that's kind of the responsibility of
season 17
um you know how do we do that and um
aware that we're kind of leading the
charge going back
to to you and james and ellen being the
three
og cast members standing have you ever
thought about or do you ever
think about closing this chapter and
moving on to something else
i know from a creative standpoint there
have been many
like oh this is how the season would end
this is how the series would end
conversations and then they all end up
you know
new because of a myriad of reasons
because the network's not ready the
studio is not ready the fan base isn't
ready the numbers are too good
and i think that collectively they've
decided you know what we're
not going to put an end on it we're just
gonna wait and see
especially in light of what's happening
right now it's like do we want the last
season to be about coven
or do we want wanted you know us to be
able to put some nice ribbons
around it with rainbows and balloons and
things
do you still feel creatively fulfilled
playing bailey every day i learn new
things about bailey with every script
just continually you know even the fact
that we're
able to see my mom in this next episode
this is
only the the third episode where she's
been able
to be present you know so there's still
something
new all the time the story hasn't gotten
old we're not regurgitating anything i
think that's the thing that i love the
most about having
been bailey for so long i think that's
what's been really rewarding and what
has also given inspiration to folks out
there to go into medicine
or because they saw miranda bailey now
they know that they can be a search
you know i still get those um kind of
you know letters notes and things
all the time that's gotta feel really
good it really does there are a lot of
fan theories that this
is the last season because you guys are
bringing back so many people
do you think that's a gift to the fans
to get us
through this pandemic or do you think it
is possible that this
is the last season i would think that if
this was the last season of graves
that it would be a whole thing about
tune in for the final season of grey's
anatomy i don't think we'd get to the
last episode and they would say that's
it right but
we love fan candy you know that's what
that's about
how would you describe the upcoming
episodes of the show are they emotional
are they nostalgic are they what would
you say
i think they end up being a combination
of both right the
nature of the pandemic is emotional
especially
um when you are personally affected we
are
in this world and you know it breathes
its own
um level of emotion somewhere in there
we have to find humor
somewhere in there we have to figure out
how we get up and go on
every day but it's all about humanizing
where we are right now so then to be
able to escape
uh and spend time in nostalgia and
lastly
what are you most excited for fans to
see from bayley
uh throughout the season wow um
perseverance we all need a nice dose of
that
even on your worst days how do you
persevere or
you know how do you even take a break
we'll see her doubt herself we'll see
her
you know at her twinkle toes best right
like all of those things is what she's
faced with but
you know bottom line is how do you take
care of everybody else
at the same time that's what's really
[Music]
important